what's up guys we're here talking about
the all-new DJI om6 it's been out for a
couple months I've had in my hands for
the past few weeks and I like some
things that I don't like something so
much but overall I gotta say this is a
really nice addition to your content
creators kit especially if you're
getting into YouTube or vlogging or
whatever it may be Instagram reels for
example if you want some really stable
recording with your phone this may be
the thing to what is this going to keep
going on like that I did that's what I
was doing oh really yeah okay now you're
working man you're working what's wrong
with you okay so anyway let's explore
this we're gonna have some fun with it
zaki's all mic'd up as well right Zacky
yep DJI Mike DGI om6 let's have some fun
play around here in the sand
with this handheld gimbal let's go Zaki
now this is a small grid from the om5
for the most part the design is
relatively the same except you now have
a telescopic arm which goes about 8.24
inches they're about
um the battery life is a little bit
longer they're saying about six and a
half hours real world usage we're
finding is around five plus depending on
how you use it you do have all your
similar features as the om5 the color is
a little bit different on this is a
darker gray but it's not a revolutionary
device from the previous one it's an
evolution but I think it's a welcome
addition I think a lot of people out
there will enjoy this but I see this for
more content creators out there now if
you are someone that uh just wants to
have a little fun with the om6 and
you're not looking to shoot reels or
tick tocks and all that stuff it may be
a little bit overkill for you because
these phones nowadays have really good
stabilization case in point the iPhone
14 14 pro Max and I mean all the latest
iPhones and even the Android phones they
do really good for stabilization so the
om6 May may be a little bit redundant in
some ways but where this does come in
handy especially with this telescopic
arms I'm using right now it allows me to
get a little bit further away and if I
want to have multiple people in a group
shot or if I want to shoot something I
want to have a little more stability
with my shot this is going to really
help versus having it closer up case in
point if I push it down here I'm going
to be really close if I gotta really
stretch on my arm on that but the
telescopic arm definitely comes in handy
in that way now you are going to notice
that sometimes this will happen what
you're seeing right here let me just
kick that back is that sometimes for
whatever reason it will just kind of go
out of whack but it does come back into
play just click on that trigger on the
back of it two times in here back in
action but for the most part this is a
really solid device and it's uh it's a
good holiday gift to be honest with you
as well if you're looking to give
somebody for the holiday season a nice
gift for their phone if they're into
Instagram reels or tick tocks or just
making some cool videos they're going to
really like this this is going to be
something that they're going to have a
lot of fun with now we're using the memo
app to record everything right now and
the memo app is going to give you a lot
of the DJI features active track and
motion zooms and all those great things
and time lapses you may use some of that
you may not use any of it but you could
also use the connect the native camera
app with this as well but you just won't
have functionality or controls so on the
grip here I have a record button I can
go from portrait to landscape I can flip
it around I can do all that with the
control right here but once you use the
native camera app you only can just
basically go portrait vertical and
that's pretty much it you know you can
use the joystick to kind of move it
around but that you're pretty Limited in
that way but I mean use the memo app the
audio sounds great the image quality
sounds great but if you want to do
cinematic 4K or something like that
that's going to have to use the iPhone
app or whatever native app you're using
on your phone what we're going to do
right now is we are going to have a
little bit of fun Zach you brought a
volleyball not just to carry in his
backpack because he likes big balls but
because he wants to actually play around
with it so we're going to do that here
we're going to put it on his tripod on
his legs here we're gonna have some fun
play around in the sand and uh yeah we
got a message from a sponsor of ours
check out this laptop you're gonna enjoy
it this video is brought to you by Asus
check out the Asus Zenbook 14x OLED
Space Edition commemorating the 25th
anniversary of the first Asus laptop
sent into space Not only does it offer a
space exclusive design but it's even
worthy of going where no man has gone
before with its space grade durability
it even comes with a 3.5 inch OLED
companion Zen Vision display and you
will have a ball of a time taking
interviews with a 16 by 10 4K OLED Nano
Edge Pantone validated 14 inch display
foreign
[Music]
I just had to turn gesture control off
because every time I put my hand up to
talk it would start recording again and
that ruins the whole vibe that's not
good
it's not good at all sometimes gesture
control works and sometimes it doesn't
if you're Italian like me and you use
your hands to talk a lot hey what am I
talking about then bam that's it keeps
recording over and over and over again
I'm Italian I can say that because we
talk with our hands it's like that okay
outside of that I mean it's really good
for stability we can run around like
this look at this super stable the
iPhone does this too
but uh I'm looking good on this Baywatch
time
awesome
so if you're wondering what audio I'm
using right now it is from DJI it is
their mic setup I have it right here on
to me and it's uh magnetically attached
the transmitter is attached to the
bottom of the phone here and it works
great
um this does not get in the way of the
phone going from vertical or to portrait
mode it works fantastic but I would say
if you're getting this mic set up
putting this dead cat on will make a
difference or a wind Muffler versus not
having it especially when you're you're
at the ocean and hearing the water crash
on the waves it's really really good but
uh yeah
that's the audio setup there's Zacky
he's topless filming me
because the sun is out yes Jackie
that's Jackie for you he's getting that
epic b-roll of me using this topless
it's that kind of Channel folks it's
that kind of Channel anyway those are
our thoughts on the om6 let us know your
thoughts in the comment section below
and if you like this review check out
more of our videos right here subscribe
guys
topazaki